the challenges with music as a business
is that nobody knows what good music
actually is unless they hear something
that they just like my name is John
Roderick Graham I'm a composer for
movies TV and video games I think that
if you're gonna be an artist to some
extent you do have to be an entrepreneur
there's a huge premium on authenticity
and bringing who you really are to
something like composing if you have a
sad scene and it's already set you don't
need to write sad music you need to
think about something sweet to recall
the person who's died if it's that kind
of a scene say you're we're gonna in
action see you sort of have to try to
respond to it in a very visceral and
intuitive way the first time you go
through it because that's how the
audience is going to experience it
they're not gonna watch it eight times
and then decide what they think about it
my timeline for business school was
pretty typical I've graduated from
college with a degree in English which
was basically poetry and music launched
into Investment Banking after college
had no idea what I was getting into I
actually only worked for a couple of
years in mergers and acquisitions before
I felt like I wanted to return to the
arts as soon as I could I think that if
you're gonna be an artist to some extent
you do have to be an entrepreneur I went
to Stanford for a Business School the
most powerful thing that Business School
did to me is it tends to focus yourself
on your career might have been Trollope
who said that if you paint for the
masses you have to paint in bright
colors there are some people who like to
compose poetry or music that are so
esoteric that only a handful of people
can understand them and I don't have any
interest in doing that I really like to
write for a lot of people the show I'm
one right now it's the most watched show
in Japan a lot of families watching it
gives me immense satisfaction to think
of families enjoying themselves together
for an hour and that the music will be
part of that I'm most proud of my
relationship that I have with my wife
and my kids I feel like that's the most
valuable thing you take away in life I
love writing music but relationships you
have with other people really kind of
what it comes down to
[Music]
you